fifteen seconds before kick-off warzone
rated fifty-one players
18:39 average rating time handicapped
thirty minutes
crazy craziness crazy town coming up
three two one let's go already
I need to get off on the right foot here
okay
what a start double those points see
five for the win and don't you dare play
Queen b6 when there's a pawn on c5 don't
you dare do it oh man
the anti the anti fishing pole can you
do there will be no Knight g5 h4 stuff
going on but my well let me try
something
there might be something over there
let's get some weaknesses okay let's
throw a knight in here play d6 and
prepare to run scared with my Knight to
d7 like that pawn push I do this let's
come over here is it safe over here that
night is pretty good over there isn't he
pond push pond push here pond push here
pond push here definitely my knight is
hanging though I'm on the bishop I'm on
the night let's run away
grab this pond oh man why did I allow
that to happen
oh this pond is going crazy I'm on the
rock I'm on the night looking night it's
got this rook no yes I really don't want
to do either I really did not want to do
either right there oh this is so scary
right here
where are my defenders but defenders oh
please say it's okay
it's really really scary over here oh
I'm getting hit I'm getting hit so bad
my Knights gonna fall
oh no no no there's gonna be a rook
check No
just dropped a [ __ ] up no say it isn't
so say it isn't so defend please please
defend please defend I can't even run
away I don't even know what I'm doing
what am i doing I gotta give up my queen
just take my queen I got a run in here
please I just want to run it hi I just
want to run your hide please run and
hide I don't have any time there's no
time you can't win this you can't win
this time this is bad this is bad
there's no time there's no time they're
gonna burn my time I'm dead
ah oh you're not supposed to lose the
first game you're not supposed to lose
any game uh where did my time go my
LightSquared Bishop Lin ah okay don't
you dare quit you have no quit and you
do you man
you don't have any quit and you do you
we're gonna see we're gonna see this is
my usual self pep talk if you're if
you're wondering about that like what's
going on why is he talking to himself
it's my self pep talk I'm not careful it
will happen again it will happen again I
will take another beating in a blink and
look at this tsunami of pawns Wow
tsunami of puns I'm getting forked and
everything no I'm not tricky night
tricky night hit a queen no don't drop
pieces don't you dare
you need to get going here you need to
get going hit a rock hit a night right
here pins pins throw they're up here
somewhere right here is beautiful I
think you're in a pen you're in a pen
rook check I have the Queen I have the
Queen check where's their main there
made it there made it okay guess how
many points I have that's two games with
the grand beefy total of zip Wow
everybody wants to start out like that
right lose that first game
win the second and then you're back to
where you started the tournament okay
you could do this you could do it you
could do it you could do it positive
thinking here positive thinking positive
thinking doesn't win games though make
positive moves right here you gotta you
gotta be positive with your moves okay I
got a piece I got a piece here I'm on
the Queen it's gonna be seen my head
note I need to have time to time burn
that's sad when I don't even have my
best friend around the clock Oh
trickiness around every corner got the
Queen come on you know you want to
resign don't you where's the mate um
just anything right
just get a throw throw a pig here I want
to stay here come on give me mate -
mating - where are you at Meghan 3
delaying the inevitable
that's mate that's mate that's made back
to China
hun come on come on come on 420 you
can't be covered can you can you recover
oh can you recover Jonathan double the
points E for for the win let's see if I
could get a better game in this time
around against mr. Jonathan I felt like
I had something last time you know you
want to Castle you know you want a
castle yes I got the pieces I got the
bishops I got the pieces pac-man mode
pac-man back to tournament they resigned
2011 10:10 hang on there there are only
6 minutes in and I can lose again I
already play this guy once didn't I I
play this guy once I'm looking to trap
that Bishop maybe let's go clean here
see for no no no no no let's go d5 I
have enough support capture here no
capture here I was close to being
trapped I think Bishop here I could I
can
away though I think I better be able to
all right I'm on the night and I take
the night
let's get developed be a developer my
queen is running way short on squares
way short let's come here problems
problems on this square I just want to
take that night why did I take that
night oh I gotta run and hide my queen
needs to run and hide come over here and
defend just take that night maybe
what is that move even doing what a
stupid move right there look at my queen
she's lovely
oh don't look at that Queen look at this
rook even better get rid of this dark
square Bishop yes that pond is running
fast though I don't want to I don't want
to move my knight just yet
I should have moved my knight Knight
right here can I get that Bishop oh I
should have played there
I should have played here I would have
got the Queen over here look at my queen
how stupid I may have how much time do I
have I don't have any time Jack come
over here
Queen trade Queen trade whoa what's
happening whoa there time burning me
their time burning me can I get a mate I
got a mean I got a mean I needed that Oh
thirty eighteen twelve twelve whoa wow I
needed that one I should not have won
that OH
Houdini Houdini Houdini was around for
that one
oh kitchen see I am getting kitchen sink
right here if I have ever seen a kitchen
sink it's this one right here that Queen
is having fun
she's a dancing queen watch out for the
dancing queen fear the dancing queen hit
the Queen get it on this square you know
you want to get there bishop here chase
that Queen around she's running way
short on squares isn't she is she she's
definitely running short on squares take
that bishop for kirovsky forks I mean
the forks are they gonna resign
they're not resigning they're not
resigning more Forks happening more
Forks but there's a fort here that's
more dangerous that's more dangerous one
avoid the dangerous Forks check and then
check here and then kick that night away
get out of there night and I just want
to push in the center oh I have this
covered no no no you can't do that you
already moved one spawn already moved
once push this guy just do that even if
it's wrong over here where does that
mean where is the main meeting - right
here clean here can I get that in that's
made that's me back to term in 28 o 56
28 28 I'm holding second barely barely
top dog cap has twice as much twice as
much Queen c7 you got to go for the
tricky stuff it's your only shot your
only chance
so go for the little sneaky stuff here
I'm gonna go just be six a single step
okay I'm getting that out I have enough
on that one ah I'm gonna take it I'm on
the okay I'm on it again it's not a mate
though oh it's close to it that is very
very close to it
there that is mate that is mate back to
tournament 4072 4028 let's go here less
than 20 kings attacker he 493 Bishop c4
f for f7 is where I want to be very soon
maybe I should have done that move
sooner um
okay with this I think knight on d5
knight on d5 take like this connect to
past pond I'm not the Queen I'm on the
Queen they missed that they're gonna
resigned they resigned back to term in
54 72-54 that top guy cap he needs to
slip up I need to get paired up against
him 7250 for 19 minutes and change the
last war
here the last warrior here no a mouse
slip a mouse slipper the last warrior
knows all about these little tricks I
mean he knows all about him they're
gonna give me that dark square bishop
though maybe one meeting one meeting one
it's so gonna be seen it's so gonna be
seen okay let's go though oh I'm on f3
f3 is where it's at a little scary being
in this pin I could get out of it though
make it once right are they gonna oh
well they cable the pond that's why
they're not moving the pond I thought
this was available it depend they
resigned back to Tremont I even realize
Oh nine games in each what's the scoop
what's the scoop it went black okay it's
not black eighteen and change how kind
let's go let's go - seven they can't
take that pond structural damage let's
do this
oh I'm gonna throw the H pond open up
that H file or not have my bishop sit
here just take this pond maybe I could
get some attack actually Bishop here
would be good let's do it now I had me I
missed me I I have made I have a bishop
I had made on e7 oh that's exactly what
I needed
ah that was a beautiful one every mate
is beautiful and that was no exception
absolutely no exception eat seven did I
or did I not have a seven right there it
was staring right at me and say that
pond was saying come get me and I didn't
want to come get him why did I come get
him he was free free pieces take free
pieces how many times have to say that
I'm gonna end up in a fork but I'm still
up come on where's the mate
where the where the mates I need to get
rid of one of these pieces they're
scaring me that night was scaring me
I get that pong let me get this ah man
man that's exactly what I needed
check where's the mate now check this is
leading to mate isn't it
King has to move that's me that's me oh
man so much time wasted on that one ten
eighty eight fifty six six we're not
even halfway done there's still a lot of
tournament left only fourteen minutes in
I could get paired up with that top dog
cap cap the top dog ah
oh man that wasn't that was important
Queen takes a seven hey watch out Bishop
I know what you're up to trying to catch
my queen
trying to catch that clean right here
okay my queen wants to stay on this
diagonal everybody's sniffing it out
they've had enough of it they've had
enough
they're like enough is enough go fish
somewhere else this is chess oh I should
have taken here sooner let me still try
for it blast that open it seems way too
good not to do I could throw a check in
what I even do that for
okay these bishops are pretty tough
aren't they these are tough guys over
here these bishops you stay here
I like this pin too much to give it up
check oh why did I do that
ooh this is good isn't it can I get that
night need to get that night it's gonna
move oh ah what does it want to do I'm
wasting too much time
13 seconds forks forks forks forks forks
this is bad this is bad maybe not man
this is so bad Queen here I can't lose
this I can't lose time burners where are
you right here I gotta take the bishop I
got it no come on come on come on I
think I can I think I can I think I can
I think I can just come over here this
is safe over here over here over here
Primo's warp removes warp removes warp
removes more pre moves right here more
pre who's crab a rook I'm sure I could
have taken a rook and stuff they got my
oh I just dropped a rook I could have
taken the rook they're down a time 128
108 I should not have won that one
either I think I could say that that
word um that phrase right there I should
not have won that one either either
being the keyword or again again would
be another good one
I should have won that one again again
everyone the clock is my best friend
it's my best friend that clocked cleany
one let's come over here f5 the bishops
unprotected push why did I play here
it's h4 or silly h4 is where you wanted
to be why am I going to g3 ah h6 remove
the dark square bishop and go for me
that's the plan follow-through
um can I get there please kill the night
no no no killed it kill the bishop and
then the knight twice or something I
could throw in ninety five uh forks I
should have done that sooner
oh okay what what are they thinking
about there's a bishop check probably
yeah bishop check is good
whoa that would have been a weird gum
combination right there but the Queen
could then have taken on h6 on the Queen
now I'm on the night
but um so what Oh actually that's okay
that's good make it once right I might
be queen
Oh kitchen sink what is that what's the
story with that get rid of the night
mate I top the real could have played to
f8 all right could have when the night
was still in g7 now it's working it'll
kill the night and look for me are they
gonna resign or they gonna have the
clock tick go go go go go go go 128 148
a 20-point lead it's not squeaky clean
he dropped back to 13 Anton's squared
um come on pair me up or don't pair me
up if you don't pan me up hit me with
the air and then give me some points
that's the trick let's go Oh nan mover
I'd rather play okay we're playing the
points need to be doubled I do they
we've been here before my opponent plays
this line quite a bit so I want to get
d5 in and I want to keep a stay out of
this pin that clean being here yeah
we've been here before I want to
preserve my bishop once placed here how
this game finished last time
oh I trap that Bishop with the pawn push
that was in the last tournament and I'm
not gonna take that just yeah I want to
maybe um take advantage of the clean
being on this file let's do this we're
gonna trade Queens I want to want to get
that bishop open this up and then I want
to get at G - if there's capture G - I
should check and it's come here that's
actually not good because of rook d1
let's be tricky thou tricky night uh-oh
uh-oh
I have mate it's made and - isn't it
making two or three bishop past a block
oh oh that's me that's me back to turn
with 148 oh man
188 188 148 10 minutes and change
Denzel is this the kind of beat me in
the it's just the guy that it last - in
the first game I think it might be the
rating rings a bell like just above 2000
that was though that was the error I
forget my opponent I forget who that was
that gave me a beating and a half get in
the corner
get in that corner here clean G 3 in
this case right here and then pawn push
or a queen H 3 let's do this I want to
break down a six maybe get to this
square if the pawn flinches flinch over
here this is a problem no this is a
problem oh no no I'm glad I'm out
slipped piston who came out slipped that
one was okay to my lip yes it was I'm on
the rook do I take the rook I think I do
that was a good mouse slip there is such
a thing that was a good mouse lift they
can't castle still over here that'll be
very cautious Bishop takes Knight is
happening clean ecigs
queen is on the bishop right here I'm on
the knight check and then where's me I
got the clean at least I got that Queen
I probably should have done something
else right here King is running I could
pre move that and then this there's
gonna be a rook check right here Queen
takes pawn watch out for rook with
discoveries but I got a mate threat
happening it's a rook check there's no
way to delay it back to tournament back
to chairman go go go go
- Oh a a 40 point lead 208 168 16 games
in by cat
the wall 22 oh man okay let's get this
pun involved the wall is throwing up a
wall of pawns right here
a wall of pawns my knight wants to get
to g3 where is that mean g3
I just want to actually get this pawn it
can't be defended
all right here this up LightSquared
bishop light square bishop and then push
that pond right here I want to be able
to push my deep on its owner take this
pond oh they're taking my pond I
shouldn't allow that to happen bishop
here before there's a Queen Minnie or
something going on there okay now pawn
push coming up on the bishop on this
pond I've got the Queen seven minutes
remaining
okay just take care where does that mean
does that mean about take its fate
that's mate that's mate 188 228 188
seven minutes and change
ah Riku alright let's go here you can do
it
can you a tough start a tough start
I miss play that a lot a real lot I jump
that night right in there that Bishop
now okay now I'm gonna take these all
around and my knight would like to get
there or here okay where's
let's push can I get rid of that night
get rid of that night even an f6 push if
the night moves do f6 clean out watching
over these squares to clean is tied down
let me just do this okay we're gonna
have a bunch of exchanges rook activity
I got to stop that tight game look up
and over can I get that in nope that's a
good move but I'm coming over here rook
activity go after the weak link he's the
weakest link got him got this one
pac-man pac-man push this one grab that
pond not anymore
let's get behind him King position next
King position King position gobble upon
one King and pawn endgame it's a one
King and pawn endgame push push push
push they resigned back to tournament to
58 to 58 give me the points they're not
giving me points I won that one give me
the points they're not giving me any
points for that win there they are
oh but knobblies up 50 points wow that's
crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy ah man you
can't overtake a 50 point lead in five
minutes there's no way you need resigner
'he's everywhere everybody needs to
resign for me pair up resigned pair up
resigned there might be enough time for
just that take here twice not yet my
rook is unprotected no if they took that
way I couldn't have done that okay I
want stuff over here take that get rid
of that dark square Bishop over here
okay back up get that battery in there
might have triple pawns get rid of the
knight get rid of the knight is the plan
here right here take that bishop
take that pond take them it's probably
okay to do that
oh it's all because I also hated to have
to I just dropped a piece get out of
their night oh man oh man I'm hoping
that that night moves he's not moving
anywhere what's going on with that I
don't want to take that I don't want
that Queen to get in there she's scaring
me let's go over here where it's safe
maybe maybe right here right here look
up and over I got to do this I gotta get
that night out of there you need to go
man
on the night at the bishop plays here no
wait matin to make it to unavoidable
it's an unavoidable back to tournament
to seventh now 288 228 60 point lead Oh
too much too much to overtake what can
you do ah it's free minutes remaining
that took those those leads that are
just so much right there 60 point lead
it takes the wind right out of me right
out of me okay man Queen to d2 Queen to
d2 these are not easy to win not easy
it's not easy one of these push in the
center push again push here push here
open up this file right here get my
knight on e4 over here
Queen d3 maybe I'll pawn push I moved my
knight somewhere exciting right here the
rook is close to trapped tonight right
here give me the dark square bishop
maybe get the dark square bishop pile up
there's got to be something juicy
happening here taking this square take
on this one this night has to go
definitely there's me around
corner right here dark squares mate they
moved back to tournament 248 288 150 288
248 145 maybe I could just get one more
game in here one more game
the Emperor the Emperor is throwing
pawns at me throwing pawns and this
Bishop wants to stop castling or even
push here that night out of there more
pressure on him pawn push if bishop
defense okay I'm on the rook at the end
of this take my pawn I could go here
first and then take the rook or the
Queen okay it's pinned mate very soon
where is the mate this is check Natan -
neighing - the King has to move back to
tournament back - chairman - 68 308 40
point lead 52 seconds where where are we
out here 112 112 are now 40 40 42
seconds 40 seconds man I'm still somehow
hoping even though 40 points in 40
seconds is very difficult to do very
very difficult impossible you can't do
it 20 seconds 18 seconds I gotta go for
craziness kill the night and then take
on h7 pair up and have a quick resigner
come on come on oh they weasel it away
take my night and go on to mate here can
I get that right here take here and then
mate right here they're calling it they
blew the whistle on it
I'm the first loser again that second
place confetti get that second place
confetti out of here ah man it's close
good games ah ah I can't even use an
excuse I can't say it was my Mouse's
fault I lost that first game